in this capsule we will see an example
of the performance of the tax collector for
concretize all this example
the execution of the tax collector's war
shadow offered an iteration especially our
training set that is given
so we have each excited pair yt
but in this case we have a very good example
simple that one only four
examples of training in our camp
of training to make an example with
a bias or I'm going to explicitly put
the baby that will be adjusted in addition to the
w parameters and learning rate
we're going to use it's going to be alpha and
wins 0.1 so we'll assume that
the user has determined that the sheet
0.1 rittenband on time to run
our mouth then what are we going to do
we're going to start by initializing
our perception so a realization
possible it would mean that wba is
equals a vector of 0 and then for this
example if the bias have earned a series
0.5 we have something else to complain about or
0.5 is going to be actually more interesting
for our example to illustrate
the updates then have an example
interesting so what do we do
begins ay terrine includes the first
hexion element there is so the first
pair in our training room and
we will do a calculation of the prediction
extra skin take off foot wm by
example as w00t 0 plus our ticket
who 0.5
so that gives an entry before the
threshold function which of 0.56 as we have
here and if we applied it it gives a
prediction of 1
now are we looking at hdx
man who is one is equal to y
a grigri is equal to 1 here so
we do not even have it
good prediction
so in this case if we do not update
our parameters w nor the baby parameter
we go to the second example so the
second example chi x 2 with the target y
two and we do it again
calculation but for the prediction for
the x2 input one aw they have to revisit
2 0 plus the bias that is still 0.5
so it goes from the same prediction that is
of 1 now in this case it's not
in a prediction that is not the same
that the desired target that is zero here
so in this case we find at
have to update w and peace bias
with the stop that we saw previously
so if we apply the vector rule
have the rule say that the new double
visit to the old w
the higher the learning rate times the
difference in place and the prediction
times the entry so my double value
life now it's 0 0 all
learning is 0.1 times the target
0 me my prediction that was 1.6
times my vector 0.3 and so if I do
this calculation gets the new w that is
zero and - 0 - 0 point 3 and could
update the bias so as we have
seen previously makes a room a bit
as a connection with an entry that
is equal to 1 it is as if we had the
same rule of the updates but with a
here so we bias it 0.5 plus the auto
learning 0.1 times the target less
the one time prediction so that's like
if we had nothing so that the good
now will go to 0.4 so we
sees that the current value of
loaded settings made me to double
life that is zero and comma - 0.3 and the
well which is now at 0.15 we pass
now third example
of training made a prediction
so we calculate h2x three gifts that are
off 0 times for 3 which is zero + - 0
point 3 x 0 I'm going all 6 0 so what
saturday 0 here plus the bias which 0.4 so
we obtain the function of thresholds on 0.4
which again our prediction goes
to be bad will not be equal to the
target who
should we and 10.0 for this example so
again update wpp
so what we get in this case
is that the new parameter w is going to be
launched by ammar which is the zero vector
and minus 0.3 plus the rate
learning 0.1 times the plate 0
least the prediction made that was 1
times my input vector they were
3 and 0 rector with the first element 3
2010 if we do this calculation hours on
gets a new weight vector that
will be less 0 point 3 - 0 point 3 and
if we do the same thing for the bias
we get a new ticket that will be
of 0.3 that it will decrease by 0.1
third example during fourth
example so now new
parameter values ​​and bias
forgiveness and good weight vectors
before - 0 point 3 months 0.3 for the
w vector and a ticket that will be at 0.3
we take our fourth example in the
training center we calculate the
prediction
so here we will have less 0.3 times a
plus - 0 point 3 x 1 what will give
- 0 points 10-6 plus my piquet of 0.3
we'll say but that's what will give me -
0.3 so we will get a prediction 2
0 unfortunately it turns out that in
the training intention the vector 1
1 was associated with target 1 so we
not equal between the prediction and
lascivious we apply again our
learning eye that makes our
new w that's going to be the current vector
for w - 0 point 3 - 0 point 3 plus
the other learning times practice
forgiveness the target minus the prediction times
the input vector which is the vector 1
it gives us a nice value of w which
will be less 0 point 2 - 0 point even
thing for beers we get a
new ticket that will be 0.15 then
that we would continue like that we prefer
a new iteration on the whole
between them
and we would continue like this until
whether we reach a number
maximum iterations or that we have
reaches a value of w and berries
our parameters as we always do
the good prediction is to say that
for this vector and its vectors there we
actually predicts a
and for this vector the inspector the dance
in training we predict well 0